[Music]
hi guys
if you enjoy my content be sure to give
this video a like so that the youtube
algorithm remembers that my channel
exists
in the dune universe the ninth planet in
the alkalorb star system
was known as ix the ixians not only
lived on the edge of the human empire
they operated in ways which pushed the
limits of the universal ban
on thinking machine intelligence
after the machine crusade the butlerian
jihad
which violently expunged all computing
technology
it was agreed during the great
convention that the violation of the ban
on thinking machines
would result in execution still
the ixians were not subjugated in the
empire
ixian technology was widely acknowledged
to be the best
so they were allowed to exist and a
blind eye was turned as long as they
didn't go too far
according to the appendix of dune ix
along with the planet reaches
had escaped the more severe effects of
the butlerian jihad
and remained strongholds of machine
technology
machine culture permeated ixian society
and this only seemed to increase during
the time of the god emperor
and after it the god emperor later the
second acknowledged the dangers of ixian
invention
he tolerated them for reasons which they
themselves struggled to understand
technological innovators no you are
criminals of science in my
empire later not only tolerated the
ixians
he employed them and put their
technology to use
many of the ixian technologies used by
laeto
seemed to defy the jihad the ixians like
the tla laksu
had many trade secrets that is to say
only the ixians truly knew how ixian
technology worked
we've discussed the ixians before on
this channel
but one of the purposes of this video is
to discuss
one specific aspect of ixian society
its governmental system the planet x was
governed by a supreme technocracy
the word technocracy is derived from two
greek words
techni meaning skill and kratos meaning
power in relation to governance
now technically a technocracy is any
system of government
in which those in charge of making
decisions are appointed
based on their own specific expertise in
a given area
but typically in science fiction there
is a heavy regard to technocracies as
governments
and which the technical experts in
charge of decision making are experts of
scientific or technical
knowledge the real world technocracy
movement began in the early 20th century
but was only popular in north america
for a brief period of time during the
1930s
before its ideas were overlooked in
favor of others which related to dealing
with the crisis
that was the great depression
technocracy
inc was the main organization related to
the technocracy movement
in 1937 technocracy inc in volume 3 of
their
magazine the technocrat stated
technocracy is the science
of social engineering the scientific
operation of the entire social mechanism
to produce
and distribute goods and services to the
entire population
of this continent for the first time in
human history
it will be done as a scientific
technical
engineering problem there will be no
place for politics or politicians
finance or financers rackets or
racketeers
social engineering in this context
relates to
the use of centralized planning in order
to regulate the future development and
behavior of the society
and manage social evolution one of the
fears that such a system
could invoke is related to the fact that
it
seems as though the human element is
being removed
science is cold rigid and unfeeling
and two what could eventually become of
giving
ultimate power to technical elites
the answer echoes what happens when
absolute power is given over to anyone
corruption but in a significantly
advanced enough technocracy
the elite class would wield even more
power over the lower classes
due to the fact that they control the
technology
as i said machine culture permeated
throughout ixian society
i pointed out in my video the fringe
worlds
that the ixians were on a path leading
towards inhumanity
lato talked about the dangers of machine
culture
and what arose from it in god emperor of
dune
when referencing the ixian creation of
we nori
who was engineered to make lato fall for
her
she makes me recall the butlerian jihad
in a poignant way
she is the antithesis of all that is
mechanical and non-human
how odd is it moneo that the ixians of
all people should produce
this one person who so perfectly
embodies those qualities which i hold
most dear
i do not understand your reference to
the butlerian jihad
lord machines that think have no place
in
the target of the jihad was a machine
attitude as much as the machines
later said humans set those machines to
usurp our sense of beauty
our necessary self-dom out of which we
make living judgments
naturally the machines were destroyed
later suggests that humankind rejected
thinking machines
because the machines took away human
individuality
and essential selfhood was lost
something about the human relationship
to machines before the butlerian jihad
was a detriment to mankind's well-being
humans had grown dependent on machines
there is a lesson in that too what do
such machines really do
they increase the number of things we
can do without thinking
things we do without thinking there is
the real danger
human dependence on machines would lead
to stagnation
and careless use of great technology
could have devastating effects
especially if those in possession of
that technology hold positions of power
in god emperor of dune lato mentions
arafel
which meant the cloud darkness of holy
judgment
he says do not fear the ixians
and he heard his own voice as a fading
whisper
they can make the machines but they can
no longer make arafel
i know i was there
here later the second essentially
reveals that one of the purposes of his
golden path
was to prevent the ixians from
destroying humanity
seemingly through the creation of some
machine-based technology
arafel the ixians operated
on the technological fringes never
considering the consequences of their
inventions
this is the machine culture that would
ultimately lead to the creation of
arafel
and because ix itself was ruled by a
technocracy
the swift execution of arafel's creation
process
was inevitable to sum things up
later the second seemed to be convinced
that the future of humanity
was interwoven with the future of
machines and he maintained a delicate
balance with ix
throughout the course of his reign
checking them when necessary
though never outright destroying them he
continued to use
many ixian devices and even pushed
innovation
on certain technologies his royal cart
was one of ixian manufacture he could
receive
information from and even speak within
the minds of those he chose by
implanting a small
device of ixian manufacturer within
their head
fish speaker nayla has such a device
lato also uses an ixian device called a
dictator
to record his thoughts when his journals
were being stolen from his citadel in
the beginning of god emperor of dune
he used his ixian devices to watch the
event
when lato made public appearances during
seanuk
he used ixian devices to project his
image to those who could not see him
directly
as well as ixian devices to amplify his
voice
ixian devices even maintain prominent
use
after the death of the god emperor their
technology may have evolved somewhat
but according to the bini jesuit mother
superior
they were a declining civilization by
that point
in chapter house dune we see that the
ixians used robos for mundane tasks
robos were non-humanoid robotic devices
such devices were far from rare in ixian
society
functional hallmark of ixian servos
busy busy busy little accompaniments to
a soldier in adjunction
or its equivalent anywhere they were so
commonplace that few people noticed them
since they were not capable of dealing
with deliberate interference they were
subsided into motionless humming
but back to the main question of this
video why didn't lato destroy the ixians
when he easily could have the answer to
this question
is of course hidden within the text and
god emperor of dune
when siona is tested in lato's desert
the character is shocked upon discovery
that lato makes use of an ixian machine
lato implies that there is also a lesson
in that fact
you see though lato knew that the ixians
may one day
invent a threat that could destroy all
of humanity
arafel he also believed that the future
of mankind
was tied to machines this is a
realization
in which mintat duncan idaho comes to in
the book chapter house do
he was fascinated by the idea of human
and machine
inextricably bound to each other each
testing the limits of the other
lato knew that the balance of human
machine interaction was delicate
but a necessary part of human survival
the benny desert essentially come to the
same conclusion in chapter house dune
when the mother superior decides to have
someone made into a cyborg
after they are gravely injured these
facts
suggest that the butlerian jihad went
too far with the eradication
of thinking machines the balance is what
was important
leto likely did not destroy the ixians
because
one humanity needed ixian innovation
two the ixian invention of arafel was
thwarted by the creation of siona
and three whatever catastrophes the
ixians did create
would act as pressures pushing humankind
to evolve
further it was all part of his golden
path
which he himself admitted was cruel she
had to be made to recognize that his
primary consciousness
worked in a friend way and that like the
terrible machines of that apocalyptic
vision
the predator could follow any creature
who left tracks
the golden path she whispered i can
feel it then glaring at him it's so
cruel survival has always been cruel
they couldn't hide she whispered
so lato in the inn did not destroy the
ixians
because they too had a role to play in
his golden path
link to the second was playing a game
far subtler than even the most complex
of benny jesuit maneuverings late to
consider it the risk
that the ixians pose to be a necessary
risk to take
for my other videos on the ixions check
out the playlist linked in the
description of this video titled
doom the fringe worlds thank you so much
for watching